well
hello how are you I greet you at 3 gonzález
with your brief information for today
wednesday september 8 a man is
dead after a shooting over tropicana
about how officers responded to
three reports of shots fired in the area
when they arrived at the scene they
found a woman with  a gunshot wound she
took the officers to a
room where they found a man
in his 30s also with a
gunshot wound however this person did not
survive the woman was transferred from the
hospital so far this is all the
information revealed by the
authorities
hundreds of people took to the streets
of the las vegas strip last night to
protest the rule of wanting to
implement the mandatory vaccine
for csd employees this demonstration
was organized by the group las vegas'
freedom of choice they do not
agree with any rule that
force people to get vaccinated around the
valley from wearing the masks
to vaccinations
and in less than a week the raiders
will open the regular season inside the
allianz stadium against last this will be
the first regular season game with
fans inside the stadium however
with the rule that they must be
vaccinated to enter if you are
vaccinated against the hobbit  you can
take your mask off during the match
the cheapest ticket with charges
included up to around 200 dollars
while the most expensive is around
2300 so avoid your hand in your
pocket
and now we move on to the weather forecast
we will have another sunny day with
temperatures reaching  108 degrees
there is an extreme heat alert that
extends until Thursday night
temperatures will drop a little for the
rest of the week but the heat will continue
for a while longer have a nice
day cheers andrés gonzález and this was his
informative prize the  end is now in
Spanish
[Music]